But my God day after day to see these howling, uh,
oppress people, you know,
like all I have decided that the narrative is that Trump is some
sort of Basquiat figure, you know,
who's just not doing anything and that people are dying because of him,
you know? Uh, it's a, it's a real shock. And I, I,
I don't want to say I'm grateful for him because I think he's meant as errors,
but for day to day, I'm sure you feel the same way.
My God, if, if the Trump administration went along with what CNN,
MSNBC and the, I'm sorry to say unspeakable,
New York times, uh, New York times a,
a venue that I've always adored and always
loved, uh, and to see what they did,
what they helped enable.
Um, I just don't know if there's any such thing as moral culpability. Um,
I think I'm so sorry to say it again. It breaks my heart.
I think the New York times is morally culpable for what's happened to this
country, uh, today.
[Inaudible].
Rubin and this is the Rubin report reminder.
Everybody locked down is more fun with friends and add free video and podcasts.
So please consider joining
us@rubinreport.com and joining me today is the editorial director at the
American Institute for economic research, Jeffrey Tucker,
welcome back to the Rubin report.
It's going to be here. Uh, Dave, nice to see you again.
Good to see you again. I'm sorry. We're not doing this in person,
but we are social distancing like everybody else. Uh,
so I guess my first question to you is, uh, well,
just how you doing, how you doing in a time of social distancing and life?
Well, I got to give the same answer anybody would, which is, uh,
I can't believe that this is the world we live in.
I never would've imagined this been three weeks ago,
but so wow. We're, we're fairing. We're not starving. We're not dying.
We're talking to people and you know, I wrote a book called the market,
loves you. And, uh, all I can say is the market,
all the bludgeoned and truncated and, and, uh,
it's never been attacked like this before, maybe in the history of the world,
it's still somehow working. So I'm very, very grateful for that.
Yeah.
It seems like the right start to this because, uh,
throughout the last month or so you're one of the few people I would say that is
making some consistent sense to me, at least on Twitter. And,
and I think you're, you're a pretty great classical liberal thinker,
which is why I want it to have here.
Cause I want to talk about stimulus and I want to talk about markets and I want
to talk about the constitution and free speech and right to assembly and all of
those things that, that I know you and I, and my audience all love. Um,
so why don't, why don't we start with this, uh,
which is just going off what you just said there,
we seem to be more resilient perhaps than, than we thought. I mean,
I think if you had said to people six months ago, Hey,
do you know that in March and April, you're going to be shut down,
locked in your house,
along with virtually the rest of the world for now going on five weeks.
And it could be months after that. I think people would have thought, Oh,
there's going to be violence. Oh, there's going to be looting.
There's going to be crime, all of these things. And yet as you started us with,
we're doing okay and the markets actually haven't completely tanked.
We were going up and down, but everything is kind of working.
Oh, Dave, I could tell you such inspiring stories.
I just want to cry when I think about it, you know,
when I go to the grocery store, which is one of the things you can do now,
it's an access to real life. And I go in there and I, first of all,
make sure to thank every single worker there for all of their,
that they're doing.
But I like to talk to the managers about how they decide what they're going to
do that day, you know, uh, was there a run on chicken yesterday?
What'd you do about that? You know, it, wasn't a run on sausage,
what'd you do about the salads, you know, over here in the deli section,
um, how you getting toilet paper,
how you rashing it given that there's restrictions on private price
movements, um, um, how has this changed your lives? You know, uh,
and all I hear is stories of heroism and brilliance and,
and it's not just individual brilliance, it's institutional brilliance,
and it's the brilliance of the market economy.
It's still working despite everything,
despite being clobbered in ways that were
unimaginable, um, just a few months ago. And if I can say, so,
Dave, um,
this brings to mind a real paradox of the times we're living through right now,
this shutdown has presumed the adaptability of
society. You know, the capacity of society to make this radical turn,
to go from one life to the other life,
practically overnight, to,
to adopt a seemingly impossible pose.
And,
and yet the government edicts that have come down have presumed the
impossibility of society to adapt to the presence of pandemic disease. You know,
like we can adapt to it.
Is that, is that adaptability.
D do you think that adaptability is unique to capitalism because of the way it
allows so many people to be in the market and innovate and move
as things need to be moved?
Yeah, it's, it's, it's,
it's an embedded in the essence of a free society where we're,
where people learn to be intelligent and learned to control their world with
people,
create these market signals that tell us about prices and interest in
all things. Um, I think, you know,
at the end of this, if you're not a libertarian,
you're not paying attention because the market is worth and,
uh, brilliantly, and it's only not worked when it's been,
when it's been hobbled and it has been hobbled, you know,
it was hobbled before this crisis actually.
And we can talk about all the specific ways in which true I blame. Um,
I don't, I get, I don't blame coronavirus for your suffering right now.
The virus has always been with us and always will be. And,
and society had developed ways to deal with viruses, medical professionals,
especially, um, have learned how to deal with, uh, viruses.
And it's a challenge for any society under any conditions,
but what you want above all else is freedom and adaptability.
And, uh,
to decentralize decision-making in the U S Dave,
for some reason, we took a completely different direction. Fortunately,
we haven't shut down the stock market.
We haven't shut down essential stores and it's thanks to that,
that we're eating today. You know,
that we're sleeping today that we're able to get by. So
we owe the fact that we're surviving through this. It's,
it's a hundred percent the element of freedom that remains in the system.
But Jeffrey,
I keep reading all these brilliant think pieces saying how this is the shows,
the failure of libertarianism and limited government, because this,
if ever, this is the moment we need big government to do things.
And the very people who have been calling Trump Hitler for four years are now
demanding that he do more with his power. Is,
am I not understanding things properly? What am I missing here?
I think you and I share the same frustration.
The response of the left has been alarming to me,
to an extent that I find indescribable,
because I think last time I was on your show,
I myself was warning about the danger of the authoritarianism of Trump.
And, and we can get into that. I think he's made some bad decisions here, uh,
and they STEM from his let's explore all of it for sure. Yeah. And he,
they extend from his own nationalism and his own, uh, illiberalism really,
um, which I think is going to be seriously problematic.
But my God day after day to see these howling,
uh, press people, you know,
like all I have decided that the narrative is that Trump is the some
sort of Basquiat figure, you know,
who's just not doing anything and that people are dying because of him,
you know? Uh, it's a, it's a real shock. And I, I,
I don't want to say I'm grateful for him because I think was meant as errors,
but for day to day, I'm sure you feel the same way.
My God, if,
if the Trump administration went along with what CNN MSNBC and
the, I'm sorry, say unspeakable New York times, uh, New York times a,
a venue that I've always adored and always
loved, uh, and to see what they did,
what they helped enable.
Um, I just don't know if there's any such thing as moral culpability. Um,
I think I'm so sorry to say it again. It breaks my heart.
I think the New York times is morally culpable for what's happened to this
country, uh, today. And I, you know, I,
I listened to the daily podcast and I saw the hysteria being ramped up and the,
and the demands for crackdowns and they the call for a medieval response to this
and that the demands for, I don't know what you would call it,
but a fascist communist, you know, social distancing policies.
And it's been grim and shocking. And I you've been shocked.
I've been shocked. I don't know what to say. I mean.
So it's so interesting that you're as concerned about the media element as
Diane, because it seems to me that we're fighting two viruses right now,
we all know about the Corona virus and how to fight that. But the,
the misinformation virus that is now permeating throughout the media,
um,
and it's New York times and it's Vox and it's CNN and the list goes on and on is
making it almost impossible for any of us to have.
What I would say is the same conversation,
because we're all dealing with different sets of information.
How concerned generally are you about that?
Oh, tremendously. I, I actually, I summarize this, you know,
we've all been talking to friends on, on, uh, what happened, right?
So throughout the day that this, I really blame, uh,
some hucksters, uh, scientists, fake scientists
computed by holding media, uh, anti-Trump media, you know, combined with,
uh, a panicked political class. And it was a kind of a perfect storm.
Those three elements came together and, uh,
led to a level of wreckage. That's,
that's unspeakable and an unconscionable morally.
I have to tell you, because, you know, for years,
people have told me about the evil of the mainstream media,
and I've never really wanted to go there. You know,
like I'm a big believer in press freedom,
and I never wanted to be one of those people to trash the New York times,
you know, and I've actually, I love the New York times I always have. Um,
but I feel like I've gotten a real wake-up call here a real shock.
I don't know how you can be in the mainstream press today and,
and be salivating over the clicks and the views and, and, and,
you know, the,
the amount of ad bias that they're generating from this while watching freedom,
just go down the drain. Um, it's, it's, it's,
it's been a shock me. I, I just can't,
I can't even describe to you how horrifying that's been to me. And I,
I have to tell you the truth. I've really turned off. I've had to.
If you're looking for more.
Yes, and thoughtful conversations about politics, instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.